la bouche théâtre ce soir jacques
évidemment théâtre ce soir dans là où ce
mouvement en attaque
d'abord parlons jazz puisque le festival
jazz sous les pommiers à coutances c'est
dans un petit peu plus de trois mois à
partir du 30 avril est à mes côtés
la trompettiste airelle besson artistes
en résidence depuis un an et demi dans
le cadre du festival est là en ce moment
bien ce sont trois concerts chez
l'habitant
vous êtes avec un pianiste important
avec baptiste trotignon qui m'a fait la
gentillesse et l'amitié de venir jouer
avec moi pendant ces trois soirs et
parmi tous les concerts que vous allez
donner dans le cadre du festival jazz
sous les pommiers airelle besson y en a
un qui vous tient particulièrement à
coeur avec l' orchestre régional de
normandie est une artiste coréenne qui
s'appelle youn sun nah
ce sera avec leur caisse de régie
régionale de normandie à peu près 30
musiciens sur scène plus un trio de jazz
trio piano basse batterie
madame youn sun nah je serai à la
trompette et on a une chef d'orchestre
avec nous merci beaucoup en attendant
via sous les pommiers
airelle besson avec l'accordéoniste
lionel suarez 20h30 vendredi soir
l'autel du de valognes notez le bien
merci jean baptiste parlons donc
maintenant théâtre comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure avec classe un
papa jacques une minute avant je vous
parlais de musique avec la school of
rock
ils sont tous collégiens
et ils ont tous découvert la pratique de
la musique et le rock à l'école
alors ça apporte quoi la musique dans un
collège ça apporte de mieux vivre
ensemble ça apporte de la joie de vivre
ça apporte la bonne humeur
et à bissau les échos
maintenant quand on fait des oraux
présomption doit rester quelque chose de
ma classe mon corps leur tendance a été
timide puisque maintenant le mercredi
après midi les professeurs viennent
bénévolement préparer avec eux leurs
prochains concerts
vous travaillez quatre heures par
semaine mais en ce moment vous
travaillez beaucoup plus que ça parce
que bientôt il ya un grande date pour
vous que le zénith de caen il est un peu
incroyable c'est vrai n'ont pas trop de
pression de jouer comme ça devant 6000
spectateurs au zénith
ben un petit peu quand même un petit peu
comme à la télé
school rock en tout ces 25 collégiens
qui monteront sur scène on a fait une
comédie musicale ya dix ans à faire et
on était beaucoup de profs sur le
concept et un moment donné avec vos
collègues on s'est regardé et on s'est
dit bon nous on créerait bien petit truc
mais à deux c'est plus facile pour
s'organiser et puis c'est parti de là
c'est parti de là tout simplement
et les élèves ont répondu présent dès le
départ le 29 janvier au zénith de cause
les deux corps venait les encourager
puis les égoutter parce que je mange ça
dépote oui cette époque je rêvais d'un
autre monde où l'on parle théâtre comme
je vous le disais théâtre h alice on est
encore ici à coutances pour parler de
jazz avec denis le bas le président de
jazz sous les pommiers denis vous avez
encore dévoiler des noms d'artistes qui
seront présents à coutances pour le
festival notamment le célèbre
saxophoniste david sanborn saxophoniste
américain qui vient avec son électrique
bande il a joué qu'énormément de gens
beaucoup de gens de la pop dont stevie
wonder du saxophone et aussi de la sole
avec la grande chanteuse bettye lavette
oui elle a aussi une figure du
jazz du blues et de la sole puisqu'elle
de l'ordre de 50 ans de carrière
enregistré avec tout le monde et j'ai vu
il ya quelques jours et ça veut dire
qu'elle est encore super forme
n'importe quoi et comme toujours des
grands voyages à travers le monde 1
grâce à des artistes qu'il est même
encore une fois d'afrique oui là c'est
la rencontre de eric bibb bluesman
américain avec un musicien chanteur
guitariste malien qui s'abat la bible
kuaté élégance classe avec le chanteur
hugh coltman will coleman revisite nat
king cole
chat sous les pommiers 35e édition à
coutances du 30 avril au 7 mai et pour
les places denis le bas les abonnements
à partir du samedi 26 mars et les noms
abonnement à partir du samedi 9 avril
mais je vous conseille de vous abonner
parce que des fois ça va très très vite
la vente des places chez nous oui voilà
maintenant on va parler théâtre
enfin avec clé si une troupe de terre à
max fini quoi c'est fini mais je vous
l'avais dit ça c'est on en parlera
demain